good morning John it's Friday good
morning Hank it is indeed Friday yes
that was a poor for today's video comes
to you in three parts part one on
announcement part two a challenge and
part three another announcement that is
different from the first announcement
part one an announcement the 2010
project for awesome is happened it's all
I might remember in 2007 when John and I
kind of realized that nerdfighter had
become a pretty big deal and we wanted
to do something with the power that
nerdfighteria wields we decided to take
over YouTube and for one day YouTube
would not be about kittens on Roombas or
about giraffe love it would be about
charity and now for three years straight
we've been doing this very successfully
and it's been getting bigger and bigger
every year this year it's going to be
the biggest it has ever been by far
there's going to be a huge epic live
show out of Los Angeles we just got off
the phone with YouTube so you do is
basically giving us the same kind of
treatment that like Conan O'Brien and
the president gets where they're doing a
four hour livestream on YouTube so
there's going to be this big live show
but they're also beep sorry ah but
there's also going to be traditional
project for awesome stuff which means
that hopefully all of you will upload
amazing project for awesome videos on
December 17 the thing to do is to show
us charities you care about in action
and I know this might sound weird but I
might involve you getting out of your
chair you might have to leave your
bedroom and that's not something either
Hank or I enjoy and we are sympathetic
to the fact that it's no fun for you but
if it makes for a better project for
awesome video it therefore makes for a
better universe and so get out there so
we're giving you some lead time this
time you have three weeks before
December 17th to plan and execute your
video and we'll be announcing more
things in the future to give you service
that was very eloquent at the end
particularly I moved and will be giving
you more details as time goes on like
the thumbnail and the logo and the
websites and etc and for those of you
who don't know much about the project
for awesome you'll find videos here here
here and here
and you'll also find some videos in the
doobly-doo part 2 a challenge we would
like to challenge you
nerdfighteria last night at dinner Hank
and I were discussing pasta pasta and
everyone knows that it is far more
efficient in terms of energy output to
create pasta than it is to create beef
and that remains true even if you import
the pasta from say Italy but we are
wondering what this remain true if you
were importing the positive from
somewhere further away to say it like
the mood like space so what we want to
know is is it more efficient to fly
apollo 11 to the moon pick up a little
pasta fill up the capsule entirely and
then ship it back would it then be more
energy intensive than growing a cow per
calorie that is our question we hope
that there are some of you who are nerdy
and smart enough to give us an accurate
answer because we couldn't figure it out
now so we are turning to you because you
never disappoint us nerdfighteria if you
successfully determine for us whether
moon pasta is more efficient than earth
beef then we will allow you to challenge
us to do something horrible part 3 the
final announcement is that you may have
noticed that it is Black Friday so in
the spirit of the holidays dftba records
is lowering prices on some new shirts
and some old favorites are you putting
Bowser trying to but your head was too
high the new shirts are the giraffe love
shirt why are the shirts on my face
because that's where they go to do dftba
shirts which we're calling the dftba
university shirts and the giant squid of
anger shirt designed by amazing
nerdfighter von Dell Swain all right so
quick recap dftba.com slash sale for all
of your t-shirt needs easy it more
efficient to have moon pasta or earth
burgers and a project for awesome
December 17th get ready and be awesome
dftba nerdfighters I'll see you on
Monday I guess I'm Keller now